よろしいんかいします
最初にこの法句経の説明がございまして
それ終わってから皆様のいろいろ質問とか聞きたいことなどを仰いましたら時間はあります
今日は何番目なんでしょう
28番目 28  パマダン アッパマーデーナ ヤダヌダティ パンディト
パンニャーパーサダ マールイヘ アソーコ ソーキニン パジャン
パッバタットホ ブッマッテ ディーロバーレー アヴェッカティー
パマダン アッパマーデーナ ヤダヌダティ パンディト
パンニャーパーサダ マールイヘ アソーコ ソーキニン パジャン
パッバタットホ ブッマッテ ディーロバーレー アヴェッカティー
という偈なんです こちらで
この章でまとめているものは全部このアッパマーダという言葉でまとめているもので
言葉一つ一つ見てみると
じとはありますけど 一番目はパマダン
パマダンというのはこの
一般的には放逸 怠ること
これをアッパマーデーナ
怠らないことで不放逸ということで
ヤダというのは時間を表す言葉で
ヌダティ パンディト パンディト
賢者はヌダティ 乗り越える時ですね
ヤダっていうのはその場合時ということになるんですね
だいたいパーリ語の文法の順番というのは
日本語で考えれば後ろから読む場合ということですからね
パンディト 賢者は 次にやるのは動詞なんですね
乗り越える時 で 各章が対角線引きに来て
アッパマーデーナ パマダン
不放逸によって怠ることを乗り越える時
時という意味でも訳できるし
乗り越えたならばという訳でもできます
たったその行だけでその 28番目の仏説ブッダの言葉っていうのはね
放逸を不放逸で乗り越えなさいというぐらいのことで
もしそれができたならばということで
また 2行目あります パンニャーパーサダン アールイヘ
パンニャーパーサダ チエというお城に
パーサダっていうのはお城ですね
大きい建物のことで アールイヘ
登って だからチエというかなり高層ビルに登ってという
何か見るんですよ アソーコ
自分が悩むことはない
悲しむことっていうのは何もない状態になって
ソーキニン パジャン 悩み悲しんでいる人々を見る
見るということは遠できません
観察するということ アヴェッカティという言葉ですけど
そこでその賢者はチエという高層ビルに乗って
自分が悩み苦しみがない状態で
悩んだり苦しんだりしている人々を観察する
もう一つ例えがありまして
パッバタットホ パッバタっていうのは山のことで
パッバタッタっていうのは山に立っているということ
いわゆる山の頂上にいてという意味なんですね
山に立つということは
山の頂上に立ってブッマッヘ
下 平らなところで 山の麓にいるバーレ
智慧のない人々 愚か者たちをアベッケティ
観察する ディーロっていうのは賢者
この賢者は観察する では
まとめてどんな意味かというと
やっぱり専門用語二つが出てきて
パマーダということとアッパマーダということ
パマーダっていうのは悪いことで
アッパマーダっていうのは良いことね
これでアッパマーダという良いことで
パマーダという悪いことを乗り越えることができたならば
その人は賢者で それは賢者にしかできないという話もありますね
それでパマーダという悪いことはアッパマーダという良いことで乗り越えるのであれば
その人は賢者で その人は何するかというと
何か高層ビルの上に立っているような感じで
あるいは山の上に立っているような感じで
下にいる何もできん人々のことを観察しているんだと
自分の状況は自分が全部悩み苦しみを乗り越えていて
でも 山の麓にいる人々はかなり苦しんで悩んでいる
これがまあ このパマーダっていうのは
怠ることという風に訳しているんですけど
これはこの我々の生き方のことで
このマダ マッドという動詞からね
アマッタという風なね
sanskrit 語ですからね
で  sanskrit 語にやっていくとアマッタなんですけど
マッドというパーリ語の動詞も考えられるし
で まあ混乱しているというかね
酔っているというかね
興奮しているというかね
というふうな状態なんですね
だから心がなんとなく興奮している状態
混乱している状態 落ち着きがない状態
で 生命は生きている  [咳]これがこの生命
どんな生き物にもある特色で
自分が本当に何をやっているかということははっきりわからないんですよ
興奮状態で落ち着きのない状態だから
何かをして生きている
いわゆる流れで生きているだけなんですね
生命っていうのは だから大体どんな人にでも「なんで？」という質問を出すと答えが出てこないんですよ
はっきりした答えはね
いわゆる「なんでこういうことをしているんでしょうか」っていう場合は
答えが出てこないんですよ
しかし みんないろんなことを意図的にやってはいますよ
面白いことは 「なんでやっているのか」というと答えがない
これがね どういうことでしょうかね
本当でしょうかね また
我々はちゃんと「なぜやっているのか」ということをはっきりわかってやっていますかと
ご飯を食べている人に聞けば 「
なんであなたご飯を食べているんですか」と
聞いちゃうと  すごく簡単に答えが出てくるかもしれませんだけど
「お腹が空いているんだから」とかね
それぐらいわかっていると思っているでしょ
違うんですよ なんでご飯を食べているんですか
今聞いたって意味がないんです
ご飯を食べているときなんですよ
答えが出てこないと思いますよ
大体そんなことを言われたってもという反応なんです
それはどういう意味でしょうかね
そんなこと言われたっても
そんなこと聞いたっても
次は何ですかね この動詞のpredicateというどうしても言わなくちゃいけない部分は
わかるわけないです  何か抱かれますよ
でも  「わかるわけないじゃないですか」っていう言葉が続きそうな
気がするんですけど だったらそれ言えばいいでしょ
言わないんですよ それでもないんですよ
自分にもわからないんですよ
だから 「そんなこと言われたってわかるわけないでしょう」とはっきりしているならば
それでいいんですよ それもはっきりしないんですよ
今 その現場じゃないんだから
そういうだけ なんで我々はよく喋る場合
よく喋っているようなんですけど
全然predicateというものがないんですよ 「
そんなこと言われたっても」とそこでストップするんです
大体喋るといつでもそういうものなんです
それはものすごいはっきり言えば
無知であるということは明確に表しているところなんです
ただ流れで生きているだけで
生きる意味もないし 生きる価値もないという
きついことなんです だから私が言いたいのは
もうくだらない理由でもね
何か持たないと で predicate
があると やっぱりあの
結構 まあ理解はしやすいんですけどね
それでこの我々は今ご飯を食べてないんだから 「
なんでご飯を食べてるのか」って 「
なんとか」というふうには言えるかもしれませんだけど
大体言えるのはね これ頭で考えるというのは「お腹が空いているんだから」というね
それ私が言ったんですけど
皆様それ考えているかどうか分かりませんだけど
でもまた他のいろんな返事が出てくるんですよ 「
今昼だから」と なんでご飯食べてるの？「今昼だから
昼休みだから」と あるいは「今食事の時間だから」
あるいはもう「これから仕事があるんだから」
そういういろいろ返事が出てきますよ
でもわかってないんです
はっきりした答え 例えば「なんであんたが泣いているのか」というと 「
この頭が痛いんだから」とかね
言うと 「頭が痛くなかったらあんたどうしますか」と 「
では泣かない」と それで「今昼だから」というのは
逆に言えば 「じゃあ昼でなかったらあんた食べないんですか」と
これがないでしょう 昼の時間でなくても食べてるんです
それで 昼っていうのは食べる時間ですか？と
昼間っていう時間がもう食べるために自然法則によってできてる時間ですかね
例えば花が咲いている
なぜかというと まあ朝だから
それは設定してるんですよ
自然法則で 朝が咲く花もあって
午後咲く花もありますし
夜咲く花もありますけど
そのその花にはそれ設定されてるんですよ
でも私たちに昼ご飯食べるために設定しているんですかね
見てください 全然生物学的には何にも理由がないんですよ
だから私が言いたいのはご飯
たとえご飯食べてたっても
なんであんたご飯食べてるんですか？と聞かれると返事持ってないんです
理由を持ってないんです
いわゆるわけもわからないということなんです
ただやってるだけで そういう人にはものすごい簡単な軽い言葉で言えばアホじゃないかと
バカではないかという反応ですよ
わけもわからないことをやってるんだから
だから仏教のお釈迦様の話の中で
ずっとこの愚か者っていうことは何のこともなく淡々とかっていうんです
そういうことで 我々はやってること一つ一つ具体的に見て
なぜそれやってるんですかと自分に聞いてみると
全然論理的な法則に則った答えが出てこないんですよ
で 論理的な時は 例えばこの階段下りようとしたところでこけそうになっちゃった
それですぐ壁を 手を出すんでしょ
あるいは手すりあるなら手すりを取ったりする
それで聞いたら なんであんた手すり取ったんですか
また掴んだんですかと聞いちゃうと
こけそうになったんだ
という答えがあるんですよ
しかし あなたこけそうになかったならば
決して手すりをつかみませんかね
どうですか これおかしくない？つかみますよ
例えば若い体力ある人だったら淡々と階段上がったり登ったりするから
年の功 方にはもう問題はありませんだからね
そういう方ではなくて
普通の人がこけそうになったんだから
手すりつかまった瞬間で
この手すりをつかんだ瞬間で聞いてみる
あんたなんで手すりをつかんだんですか？だってこけそうになったんだからとすぐ返事は出す
そこで逆にまた質問してみる
では あなたはこけそうにならないならば
決して手すりをつかむことをしないのかと言うと
いいえ それはつかみますよと
つかんだりつかまなかったり
いろいろでしょ だから
なんでその人は手すりをつかむんですかね
理由がなくなっちゃうんですよ
で こういうこのすごいシンプルな単純なバカバカらしい例をなぜ出すかというと
こういうものをずっとつなげて我々の人生っていうものになっているんだからなんです
みんなに人生の問題解決できないのは
すごいバカでかい問題抱えているんです
存在しないんですよ 小さなこのすぶすぶで
小さな核で見なくちゃいけない
だって 1 秒単位で生きているんだから
あの 3時間単位で 6時間単位で生きているわけないでしょうに
1 秒単位でもない もっと早いんですよ
ですから 我々やっている行為っていうのはすごい小さな粒なんですよ
それはもう 1年間の分をまとめて
私のすごい問題がありましたよとかね
言ってもわかってるわけないんですよ
ただ単になぜ手すりをつかんだんですかと聞いたってわからない人がどうやって 1年分の人生問題解決しますかね
で それで私たちはこのずっと 24時間も朝から寝るまで
また寝ている時もいろんな行為はする
いろんなことをやってますけど
一つにもなぜそういうことをしているのかっていうことにははっきりした答え
これしかないという答えを持ってないんです
大体別なことをしたっても
別に悪くない場合いっぱいあるんですよ
ということはどういうことでしょうかね
これが生きる上で大変な問題ですよ
これが解読しないんだから
もうみんな発見しようとしないんだから
大変な問題なんです できるだけ具体的な例で考えてほしいんですよ
例えば なぜあなたは子供を叱ったんですかと
なんかちょっと悪いことしたんだからって言うでしょ
では 叱らないで別な方法はなかったんですか？しつけするためには
まるっきりなかったんですかと
それしかないと 例えば
あの どこか燃えているんだったらもう消すべきでしょ
他の答えがないんですよ
家の中で何か燃え始めたら
それは消すべき 他の答えは存在しない
消すまで待ちましょうとかね
あるいはその火の周りでぐるぐる回ってみましょうとかね
あるいは家が火事にならないようにというお札がありますからね
さっさと行ってそのお札持ってきましょうとかね
そういう返事一つも 何て言いますか
選択一つも通じないんですよ
では 消そう ということがなるんです
そういうことで人は悩んだりはしませんよ
では 子供はなぜ叱ったんですかというと
これがだからと言うんだけど
では 叱ることを叱らなくても別な方法もあったんでしょうかと言えば
やっぱりあるんですよ
いろいろ では なんであんたこれ選んだんですかと
選択 4つあったのに これは一番優先順位の 1番目の選択ですかと
選択いくつかあるということは
どちらでもいいということでしょ
その中で一つ選ぶ場合は
だからこれは哲学的に考えちゃうと難しいんですから
できるだけ単純な例ばっかり並べて並べて考えた方がわかりやすいんですよ
これは一つのこの思想と体系として考え方としていうとすごい難しいことなんです
それで残念なことに あの
ちょっと何か萌え出したとかね
そういうふうにはっきりした答えがある出来事っていうのは
人生にはそうたくさんあるわけじゃないんですよ
いくらかあるだけで それはそんなにもう悩むことなくやってますよ
で ここから出かけなくちゃいけないんでしたら
皆様のそのその 例えば新宿の行く方々だったら
もう選択一つしかない
もう幡ヶ谷駅まで行くしかないんですよ
自分の家にはもうあの丘の
例えばなんとか何でしたっけ
代々木上原の方が便利だなと思ったら
そこまで歩くしかないし
後ろにあるあの駅何でしたっけ？笹塚
笹塚の方が便利だったら笹塚の方に行けばいいし
そちらで選択いくつかあるわけじゃないんです
それに悩んだ人っていないでしょ
なんで幡ヶ谷駅に行ったんですか？と言って
私はもう新宿に行きますからという
はっきりしているんです
でもあなたにはこの 何と言いますか
このこの電車じゃなくて
笹塚方面の電車に乗れればよかったんではない？いえ
よかったわけじゃないんだ
逆だから それは上り方面の電車に乗らなくちゃいけないというふうにはっきりしているんです
その場合は 因果法則というものはしっかりしているんです
しかし そんなことというのはそうたくさんあるわけないんですよ
はっきりしたものは ほとんど私たちがやっていることは
なんでやってますか？と聞いたら
大体わからない これがすごい問題ですよ
それが問題かもわかってないでしょ
結局は そう言われたっても
そこまでわかってないです
面白いことに それは例えばね
皆様もお互いにご存知でしょうし
いろいろ問題もって まあいろんなことで悩んでるんだ
自信がないんだ もうなかなかもう明るくならないんだとか
いろいろごちゃごちゃ言ってるんじゃないんですか
私にも それで私は言うでしょ
なんでそんなくだらな
考えてるんですかと それやめなさいと
あなたの妄想でしょうと
妄想のせいでしょうと
ああそうですかと言ってわかったような顔をしているんだけど
妄想それでもやり続けるでしょ
あれ なんででしょうかね
だから結局それが問題ですよ
大問題ですよ なんで私はこういうことをしているんですかということをわかってないんだから
必ずしも失敗するは トラブルを起こすは
不幸に陥るは 苦悩に陥るは
これはもう避けられません
例えばいくつか選択あったのに
ただもう子供を叱ったというケースは
これがこの小さなことというのは
積み重ねて積み重ねて
何年も積み重ねると大問題でしょ
子供に殺される そう言ったら私は大げさに
大げさじゃないんですよ
もう今日もニュースであったんだからね
もう台風もう日のケースなんですけどね
若い大学生と もう高校生の女の子がもう親を殺しちゃったと
だから でも問題はどちらにあるんですか？どちらにもあるんですよ
殺された親にもあって
殺した側にも なんで殺すんで他の選択なかったんですかと
だから このずーっと子供頃からもう
まぁ なんとかやってきてるんだから
これなんとかやるんですよ
こうなんとかやることっていうのは大問題じゃないんですかね
それで殺された時のその親の気持ちっていうのはどうでしょうかね
これほど愛情いっぱいで可愛い可愛い一生で育てた人に殺されると
親っていうのは 子供がどんどん大きくなっても楽しくてたまらんでしょうね
男の子だったらえらいごっつい大男になってくるともう楽しい楽しい
自分がすごく小さく見えるんですけど
やっぱり子供はすごいいい男になっていくことはすごい楽しい
女の子も同じくすごい立派な女に成長すると
もう楽しいでしょうね
それで体力があって で
親を殺すと 親の悲しみ
どうにもならない精神的な状態
どういうことかというと
ちょっと想像した方がいいんじゃないんですか？この自己破壊になる妄想ばっかりしているんですけど
そういう風なちょっと面白いことを妄想したって悪くないんですよ
どんな気持ちになるでしょうかと
で そこは不幸でしょ？結局は
それで殺した側どうですかね
あれで幸せと思ってるんですかね
で あの女の子もなんかこのニュースで見たんですけど
えらい自殺願望で自殺した男もそういうこと言ったみたいですね
自殺したかったんですけど
怖かったと なんて情けない人でしょうかね
自殺したいなら自殺したらいいでしょうに
怖かったんだったらやめればいいでしょうに
その代わりに親を殺すという
これちゃんと論理的な生き方ですかね
だからそこまで発展するんですよ
この曖昧中途半端いい加減な生き方っていうのは
そこで私たちはすぐ開き直る
私たちはそんなひどいことはしませんとかね
本当はもっとたちが悪いんですよ
あれは一発で解決しているんだからね
これがずっと年 年までごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ悩み苦しんで続けているんだから
まとめてみれば同じですよ
あの若者二人がそれでまあ裁判やらそこそこでそれなりのことで決めちゃいますからね
だから我々の生き方というのはそんなもんで
まあ曖昧で 結局は何でご飯食べるんでしょうかと言っても
ぴったしすばりという答えは持ってない
それでみんな私に逆らって言うのは
そんなのはないんだよと
ありますけどね 本当は
ないんだよと言えたものじゃないんですよ
ないと言えるほどあなたしっかりしていますと私は逆に聞きますからね
人生はもう曖昧のは当たり前と威張っている人々いますよ
人間は白でも黒でもないんだと
灰色はいいやとかね だったらそれも曖昧でいてほしいんですよ
なんで人一つだけそうやって偉そうに言って
あんたわかってるんですかと
曖昧だったらそれも曖昧でしょうに
言えないでしょうに その時点でも矛盾でしょ
これはね 全くも目が見えない人々が集めて色について語るようなもんですよ
みんな自分自分の意見を持って
色ってどういうものかとかね
私はやっぱりぐらいあると思います
もう一人 いえいえ もっとあるんじゃないの？私はあると思いますよとかね
もう一人 いえいえ そんなたくさんじゃおそらく色っていうのはつぐらいだと思いますよとかね
この人々はまるっきり目が見えない人々はね
何喋ってもこの曖昧で中途半端で何にも至らないでしょうに
だからお釈迦様は世界はアンダーアチャックか
世の中の人々というのはアンダー目が見えない
アチャックか目がありませんと
だからもういくら考えても
いくら解決出したっても
目が見えない人の色についてのディスカッションみたいな感じで
もうどうにもならん状態なんです
それが我々の人生なんですよ
どうにもならん ただ流れるだけ
流されてるですよね この流れる流れをちょっと見て
犬かきでもいいんだからやってみようという気持ちはないんですよ
だから流されていると岩にぶつかるかもしれませんでしょ
なんであんた岩にぶつかったの？じゃあバカか
岩あったんでしょ？でもしょうがないでしょ
流れるんだからという答えでしょ
それでこちら渦巻きが見えるでしょうにと
なんであんた渦巻きに引っかかったんでしょう？だってしょうがないでしょ
流れるんだからと 犬かきでもできる人は岩が見たらね
あ これやべえと ちょっともう避けようとするでしょうね
泳げなくても そういうことで
私はなんでそこまでこのこの行ったかというと
この あの 物事ははっきりしていますよ
これがブッダがのブッダの教えの特色なんです
１足す １は２に決まってるんです
１足す １は まあ１からもう 1000 まで一つだよっていうのは答えじゃないんですよ
どちらでもいいんで この曖昧さは良くないということで
私もう学校でやる先生はいい
もうなんかいつでも文章いろいろ論文書かされますからね
向こうは昔のやり方で
もうしょっちゅう 1週間に１回とかね
書かなくちゃいけない
日本の誰か相撲さんがね
あのたまたま大学に行って大学院で勉強してるという話をテレビで聞いたんですけど
そういうふうにたまたま言ってはできない
向こうは で それでも あなた方はね
もう何でもいいんだからと書いて持ってくるなよと
捨てますよ 全部 先生怒鳴ったんです
それで もうそれでも書いたものをいろいろ読んで
我々はえらく侮辱したんですよ
あなた方の論文なんか読んでみると
自分がこの幼稚園の子供が書いた論文
作文を思い浮かびますよと
ある幼稚園の園児に あの
えーと お母さんについて何か書いてくださいと
頼んだと それで子供は
私はお母さんは大好きですと
なんとか書いて お母さんのことを書けないんだから
お医者さんのことを書きますと ２
行目で でお医者さんには
あの足４本あって しっぽもあります
また おっぱいもありますと
それはどこかにありますという風に文章があったんですと
そういう風な文章になりませんと
だからおっぱいはあるんだけど
まあどこかにあるでしょうというのは
このどこかじゃなくて
ちゃんと場所が決まってますからね
お医者さんのおっぱいはどこかどこでもいいんだから話じゃないんですよ
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
物事にははっきりした答え
はっきりした方程式っていうのがあるんだよと
だから 大雨が降ると山火事になるっていう話がないでしょうに
なぜ山火事になったと
今大雨だからと そんなこと言ったらね
３ヶ月間も雨が あるいは半年間も雨が降らなかった
乾季 この頃風は強い 山火事の恐れもあるでしょ
それだったら だから物事ってのは曖昧じゃないんですよ
我々も自然の一部でしょうに
なんで私たちだって曖昧ですかね
いい加減ですかね だから人生っていうのはもう明らかに決まって
不幸に苦難で生きていなくちゃいけない
不満で文句言いながら納得いかない生き方しなくちゃいけない
納得いかないのは当たり前
子供を叱ったと なんで叱ったと聞いたってもわからない
その時点で叱ること以外いろいろ選択はあった
なんでおっぱいはどこでもいいんだからという法則で
例えば絵を描く 牛の絵を描く
おっぱいどこでもいいんだからおっぱい描きなさいよと
言うと それでいいわけじゃないでしょうに
それでみんなピカソでいいんじゃないかなと
言うかもしれませんだけども
残念なことにピカソっていうのは一人しかいないんですよ
皆様ああいう風に絵を描いちゃうと
もう精神病院に連れて行くな
一千万円で買うどころか
だからまあピカソにはそれなりの論理法則がありましたから
おっぱいは頭の上に描く法則は
だからどこでもってわけじゃない
例えばピカソの絵の考えたって
おそらく彼がいろんな場面をね
一つの紙の上に積み重ねたんでしょ
だからあっちこっちにはなる
見る人はそれ一枚一枚一枚見ればいいんです
で そちらにもちゃんとした論理性があるんだから
その絵は評価される って言っても一般人が評価するものだから
私は評価しているわけじゃないんです
ただただみんな言ってることを言っただけ
その評価も絵もどちらでもどうってこと大したことないんですけど
まあとにかくこのおっぱいはどこでもいいんだから描きなさいというのは生き方は良くない
それで子供はなんで叱ったというと
まあそれはとにかくいろいろあったんで
まあその叱ったという状態だからね
それで自分が得た結果は自分が納得いかないんですよ
なんでこんな子になったんでしょうかと
今更そんなことを言っても
物事は自然法則だからどうにもならないんですよ
一足と一は一は二に決まってるんだから
二  三週間大雨が降ったら洪水になる恐れは決まってあって
山火事はないんですよ
もういくらなんでも なんでそこまで期待するんですかね
阿鼻叫びでしょう だから自分がやってる行為にはきっちりと正しい結果が出ている
そこで その行為をやっていた時点で自分が好んでやってるんです
例えば子供が叱ったことは好んでやってるんです
だったら結果も好んで受けるしかないんですよ
子供が包丁を持って母親を殺そうすると
ああ良かったと 私の今までの子育てのやっと結果が出ているんだと
やっと実ったと 希望通りと喜ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから曖昧もいい加減で
それについては曖昧で
なんでこんな結果になるんでしょうかと
またまるっきり関係ない人に聞く
どこかの誰かのカウンセラーやら誰かに聞く
会ったこと見たこともないでしょうに
この家族環境なんかは
あるいはアメリカで誰かが書いた本を読んでみる
自分の息子の問題に対してとかね
面白いですよ もう それは歯磨き方をカラスに聞くような感じなんですよ
カラスには歯がないんだから
カラス知りません そんなことは
だからって歯がある猿に聞いてもね
それは別に磨く必要ないんだよと言うでしょうに
そういうことだから 関係ない人のアドバイスを聞いても結局意味がないんですよ
これでいろいろアドバイスを受けたのに
いろんな特別学校なんかに入れたのにとかね
うまくいかなかったとか
まだ悩んだりするっていう
そちらにはきちんとした法則があります
そこはすごい単純で理解しなさいよと
そうすると何でもうまくいきますよと
世界は曖昧ではありませんと
人生も曖昧 中途半端ではありませんと
全て厳密に法則によって機能しているものだっていうのがブッダの教えなんですよ
そこでこのパマーダの説明
放逸の説明と こちら何か関係がないようでしょう
こういう生き方に放逸な生き方と言うんですよ
いい加減な生き方 パマーダっていうのはそれなんです
何か分からないんだけどやっている
だったら結果も自分ではわからないんです
しかし 仏教から見れば
いい加減あべこべなことにはあべこべな結果だよということは仏教は発揮している
だからお釈迦様はまとめてみんな苦労しながら不満で納得いかないで文句言いながら泣きながら悲しみながら生きているんだよと
憂い悲しみに陥って生きているんだろう
結果は決まっていると
厳密によ こういう生き方に
いわゆる我々一般的な
毎日どんな人間でもやっている生き方にパマーダと呼ぶんです
特別にわからない言葉ではないんです
なんか放逸なんか言っちゃうと
なんか特別な概念で感じちゃうでしょ
あの人やってる 私はやってないんだけどという態度になるでしょうね
そういう人もいるんですけどとかね
例えば子供が親を殺したと言っちゃ
やっぱりそういう人もいるですね
この世の中で悲しいことに偉そうなことを言うでしょうに
他人のことだから それは甘くないんですよ
これは自分の問題なんです
だからパマーダは放逸だと日本訳しちゃうと
なんか自分に関係ないような感じがしますけど
結局我々人類の生き方にパマーダというんです
だからなかなか訳しにくい言葉なんです
その我々の人生 生き方そのものがパマーダでしょうし
だからパマーダというのは生きることなんですよ
結局は それをどう言うかというと
因果法則にはまるっきり関係なく
もうこんなのは知ったものじゃないという感じで
何かやればいいんじゃないかと
何かやればいい結果が出てくるんではないか
何かの種をまく 何かの種をまいて
ある特別な収穫を期待する
これはありえないんです
何でもいいんだから この手当たり次第見つけた種を撒きましょうと
そうすると来年はメロン食べられますよと言うとね
面白いでしょうし しかし我々はすごいその面白い人生をやってるんです
もう何でもいいんだから
もうどんな種でもいいんだから撒け
来年はメロン食べられますと
君はメロンの中でもどちらの方が好きですかと
私はこういうこういう種類のメロン
じゃあ来年食べられますと
食べられるわけないでしょうに
そういうまるっきり信じられない
非論理的なおかしい生き方がすべての人間がやっています
それにパマーダという生き方と呼ぶんです
だから賢者はこのアッパマーダという全く正反対の生き方で
これは乗り越えてみる
ですからアッパマーダというのは何でしょうかね
しっかりとこういうことだからこういうことをするんだと
それしか別にやることはないんだと
選択は一つだよ という厳密な生き方なんです
だからそこをその人に賢者と知識人だと言ったら
これ並大抵の智慧じゃないでしょうに
だからブッダに質問されると
ブッダのどんな言葉でもそういう風に
この並大抵の智慧ではないんですよ
では またサンプル出します
階段こけそうになった
若者が それで手すりをつかむ
で 私は歩く なぜ手すりをつかむのか
こけそうになったんだから
しかし それは正しくはないんです
手すりっていうのはいろいろ理由で人はつかみますよと
ただ手を振るよりは まあ気分がいいんだから
足が弱く 足腰が弱くて階段は上りにくいんだから
階段から転がって落ちないようにという
という理由で人は階段を上ったり下りたりすると手すりをつかまえます
つかみますよと ここで私はこけそうになったんだからつかみましたと
今は という答えなんです
それで私には反論できないんですよ
あんたは階段 手すりをつかむのはこける時ですかと
反論できないんです だってなぜ人が手すりをつかむのかということは全部言ってるんだから
その中でその条件ではもうこれやと
そういう態度でブッダの返事
全部そういう態度なんです
そういう風に答え出すためには
かなりしっかりしていないと
曖昧模糊たることはできるわけじゃないんです
それでアッパマーというのは
そういうきっちりした論理的な生き方
これがとてつもない智慧なんですよ
でも お釈迦様はそれを獲得する方法っていうのはそんな難しいことじゃないんだと
もう人間っていうのはもう秒単位で生きていることでしょうに
だから 駒ごとに動いているんだから
その瞬間 その瞬間ではっきり原因結果
決まってるし そこをチェックしてみなさいよと
もう頭が綺麗になりますよと
あの なんとなくやったことっていうのは全てなくなります
全て無駄が消えます だって論理的だから
穏やかにもなります だから抜群の智慧が生じてきます
信じられないほどの智慧が
そこでこの放逸をなくして不放逸にするということは
私自身がやらなくちゃいけないでしょ
隣のお母さんはしっかり子供を躾しているんだから
うちの子供まで良くなりますかね
隣の家はものすごくごちそうを毎日食べてるんだから
こちらはえらい気分がいいんですかね
食べなくてもいいってことになるんですかね
隣の奥さんが今日は食料は二万円もの食料を買いましたからね
晩御飯に じゃあ私たちはまあじゃあ二百円
三百円ぐらいにしましょうと
これは話にならないでしょ
そんなことは だから自分がいい加減できてるんだから
いい加減にならないように生き方は自分がしなくちゃいけない
これを人に頼んだって
あなたしっかりしなさいよと
なんの意味もないんです
これで この この偈はこのマハーカッサパ大長老に対してお釈迦様が言った歌だと言ってますけどね
それでこの あ そちらに戻る前に
この もし人がしっかり秒単位で物事を観察して生きている
私たちは一秒しか生きてない
この一秒っていうのは皆様にわかるために言ってるんであって
一秒より一秒っていうのは仏教から見れば長すぎ
こんなすごい時間で取るなよと心理を
人間っていうのは十年計画
二十年計画で生き方考える
これというところじゃない
仏教から見れば一秒も長すぎですよ
しかし 我々にはわかりませんだからね
瞬間ということはね で
一秒で一秒で生きているんだから
その一秒しっかり生きていればね
一秒ぐらいっていうのは何のこともないでしょうに
たった一秒だから たとえ火を触ると言ったっても
一秒だけぐらいだったら触れるでしょうに
別に だからすべての人生一秒でできているのに
なんで生きることは大変だ
あの問題解決することは大変だとか言ってますかね
これも仏教から見ればあまりにもあべこべ理屈で
それで人がちゃんとそういう瞬間単位で生きるということは
ちゃんとしっかりと身についたならば
その人にとっては何一つも苦しみもないわ
悩みもないわ 落ち込みもないわ
憂い悲しみもないわ ものすごく穏やかで
どうしようどうしようどうしよう
それ全然ないんですよ
別に どうしようといって時間をなくすんじゃないんだから
どうしようと言ったと
もう一秒取ってるんだから
一秒間悩んだんですよ
曖昧で もったいない だからすっごく充実感に溢れて生きている
別に大胆な生き方とかね
何もない ごく普通ですよ
信じられないほど充実感で生きていられる
皆様 宗教で考えている何か
例えば悟ったら何か偉いオーラが出たりとか
体から何かあの もう何て言いますか
港にある 何でしたっけ
あれは あの 灯台みたいに
偉いかっこよかったとか
そんな冗談じゃないんですよ
別に あれはずっと神様から毎日毎日あらゆる恵みを降ってくるとか
悟った人になんもないんです
ごく普通みんなと一緒に生きてるんですけど
想像を絶する充実感で
想像を絶する喜びを感じて
あ どうしようというあの瞬間の悩みもないんです
あ しまったとかね 何も締まりません
全部解放した状態で 私たちの人生一生しまったもんだからね
手も足も何も出ない ぎゅうぎゅうで
だからそういう風に信じられないほど自由を得た人
奇特な自由を得た人が
この愚かどもたちを見ているんだと観察しているんだ
なんだこの連中という感じで
自分たちも一人一人やらなくちゃいかんのに
犬かきもしないな こいつはとか
こちらすごい崖があるのに
今頭がぶつかるでしょうねとかね
えらい痛くなるでしょうとかね
これでいていていっていると
次でまた渦巻きがあるんだと
これでやられちゃいますと
これで終わらない 次にはいろいろ生粋パクパクと人を食ったりする魚もいるんだよと
それでまた泣くでしょうとかね
そうやって観察しているんだと
山の頂上に乗って下 地面に住んでいる人々を見るような感じで
あるいはお城の上に乗って
自分がえらい安全な状態で
こちらですごい喧嘩 もう戦争している
まあどうしようもなくこうやって見ているんだと
これなんとなく辛い態度だなという感じにありますけど
人が悩んでると ここはあえて言っているところなんですよ
間違わなければ 大変だ
助けてあげたいけど助けられませんだからね
あれが人間の曖昧な思考なんですよ
これでまた騙されているんです
苦しんでいる人々は救い出すとかね
救い出しません そんなにも苦しみたければどうぞご自由にという態度なんです
だからこの救済論は仏教でないんです
これは非科学的であると
あまりにもあべこべであると
だから誰かに救ってもらおうと思ったら
あんたはもうもう決まってます
行くところは だから この自分が期待する結果とまるっきり反対の結果になるということは悪口になりますけど
神様の恵みであって 天国に行こうと思ったら逆になるんです
結果は これはどうかってあまり言いたくはないんです
救済者に自分の身を任せると
まずそういう人はいない
だからナビゲーターがない船に乗ったという
前兆が 船に乗ったと それで目的地に行きますかね
遭難するだけでしょうに
だから人間っていうのはあまりにも怠けで
あまりにも放逸で 誰かを神様は信じるといういい加減なところで
それはありえないんです
この因果法則の世界では
全て精密に因果法則でできているんです
だから自分の心は自分でちゃんと管理するしかないんです
無理不可能ですよ これ世の中見たらわかるでしょうに
隣の人はすごい美味しい弁当食べてるんだから
ああ美味しかったと言えますかね
言っちゃうとそれ自体で頭がおかしいでしょうに
あの人はベンチで寝ているんだから
やっぱり私はよく あの
何て言いますか あのリラックスできましたと
よく休んだと そんなことはないでしょうに
だから法則というのは
自分でやった分は自分のもので
他人がやったものは他人のもので
それも否定するんですよ
他人がやったものは自分のものにしようと
ホッソボサッツが修行修行したんだだから我々みんな救われますよと
よっぽどおかしかったでしょうね
そんな話思った人々は
そういうのは信じる人々もね
なかなか負けませんね
この理屈を連れているところには
だからこの自分に自分しかないんだよということはすごく強調したいんですよ
だから悟った人はみんなのこのかわいそうな愚か者たちの生き方を見ているんだと
これ出来事は このマハーカッサパ尊者が
まあかなりこのあまりこの社会には出てこなかったんですね
お釈迦様と身体がほとんど似ていて
あの時々後ろ姿なんか見ちゃうと間違っちゃうんですよ
もしかするとお釈迦様ではないかとね
で そういうことで まあ二人ともすごくもう細かったでしょうね
お釈迦様も結構細かったんですよ
体は あの仏像を見たら勘違いしてはいけません
それで偉大なるお釈迦様に対してはね
これはすごく失礼で 人間が罪を犯す可能性もあるし
ということで マハーカッサパ尊者はできるだけお釈迦様あるところには来ない
どうしてもお釈迦様会いたくなった時とかね
まあ大きな大坊さんたちの集まりある時しか出てこない
どこかで まあ別室に生活
ある日 自分がこのある洞窟の中にそこで住んでたんですよ
お釈迦様 たまたまそちらを訪ねたりもします
そこで自分が瞑想禅定に入って
このこのあれは この何でしたっけ？宿命ではなくて
チュトゥーパパターニャーナという能力があるんですよ
生命の あの 生まれること
死ぬことは もう何かテレビで見ているような感じで見ている
ここで自分のその超越した智慧で
あらゆる生命がいろんなことをして
こうやってなく死んじゃって
ここで生まれているんだとかね
この人は今こういう風な運命になっているんですけど
過去でこういうことをやったんだからとかね
あの人はこういうことでとかね
そうやって ただただ業によって人々は生まれて死んで
またまた再び生まれている
その過程やらを見ているんですよ
それはいろいろなケースで見るんですよ
例えばある人にを狙う
あの人は今こういう生き方で
なんでこういう生き方の結果を出したかというと
この人はこの子のせいで
こういうこういうこういうして
今こうなってるんだと
そこで死んでる人々はいくらでも世の中っているんだからね
どんな瞬間でも誰かが死んでいる
どんな人間だけじゃないんだからね
今あの生命は今死んでいる
今死んだと死に どこに生まれた？あちらに生まれましたとそこでこういう業で生まれたんだとかね
無数にあるんだから 瞬間で
それはもう一応いろいろ適当に手当たり次第ケースを取ったりして見ているんですね
そこで何かお釈迦様はもうそれに際してこの偈を唱えたと
まあだいたいその偈の意味はこれぐらいのことなんです
で ポイントはパマーダとアッパマーダという二つは何なのかと
各偈に対して私はパマーダはいろんな方法で提起しますけど
いろんな角度で でも疲れちゃったんだから
まあこれからまああまりパマーダの提起する必要はないのかなと思いますけどね
で そういうことで頑張ってみてください
パマーダっていうのは
なんとなく生きてることではないんです
しっかりと厳密に正しい論理と因果法則に沿って生きてみること
これにはすごいとてつもない智慧が必要なんです
その智慧っていうのは秒単位で生きてみると身につくんです
ということはヘソなんです
今日の話の いいでしょうかね
もう長い時間喋りました
今のアッパマーダ  そうです
アッパマーダとパマーダはどうします？ そう
じゃあ訂正してください
それはアッパマーダの生き方なんです
先生 あの まあ助けることはできんけど
教えを聞いてなんとかっていうことは
それは聞く 聞く人がいれば教えることが可能なんじゃないですか
もうちょっとこのアッパマーダにもとづいて質問してみてください
だから うーんと 自分の心を
だからそのアッパマーダをどういうふうなことがアッパマーダかよくわからないけども
アッパマーダでやろうという人がいた時には
そのアッパマーダにたどり着いたその聖者は手助けして
こうやったらアッパマーダですっていうことを厳密に教えてもらうことができるから
その山の上とか城とか
絶対安全地帯で手を出さないというわけではないんじゃないんでしょうか
だからそう言ってるでしょうに
仏教って何でしょうかね
自分がやればいいんですけど
やり方書いてるでしょうに
そのようにやればいいっていうことでしょうに
そうです  それ以外は手を出せません
だからマラソンだったら
まあこういう風に訓練しましょうとかね
こういう食べ物を食べなさいよとか
ちゃんと言ってるのにやってないんだったら誰のせいですかね
だから あの  だからマラソンは決まってる時間以内でもっと速く
記録的に速く走れるように全部教えている
それはそのまま足で蹴っ飛ばしちゃって
私はその時走って見せるぞと言ったら誰のせいですかね
だからできることは全部やってますよ
だからマラソンは記録的に記録を出してゴールに達せれるように方法を教えているんです
これは他宗教と比較してお釈迦様はたった二週間でもやってみなさいよと
どうでしょうかと そこまで言ってるのに
だからもうこれはこの心境状況は説明してるだけで
あの 悟った人はどんな気分かと
マラソンで記録出すためにはと
百パーセントの確実な方法っていう風に仏道
仏教は語って語られてますからね
これ以上は手を出せません
コーチはできるけど 走るのはあなた
うん  じゃあ先生 この一礼で質問
質問受けましょう  はい
じゃあ皆さん ただ今から質問
質疑に入りたいと思いますので
もし何か今日のことでお聞きになりたいことがありましたら
どうぞ遠慮なくおっしゃってください
マイクお渡ししますね
すいません 届かないところは前に出てきてください
すいません  今のお話とちょっと通じるんですけれども
あの キリスト教徒のお友達がいて
それで仏教とキリスト教についてちょっとお話したんですね
そしたらキリスト教は歴史の中で結構悪いことしてるけれども
今結構 何て言うのかな
社会活動とかいろんな困った人をいっぱい助けてるから
結構 何て言うか 有意義な宗教だけれども
仏教は何もしてないじゃないかっていうような感じのことを言われて
僕も何て言っていいのかなと思って
といえば あの まあそれもそうかなと思ったりして
簡単ですよ  百人殺して一人を助ける
一人も殺さないで どちらが立派ですかね
何をね 仏教ほど社会に人類に貢献してないんですよ
あの連中は 今も悪いことやってるのに何言うんですかね
今も人を殺してるでしょうに
どこかに病院作ったんだからと
なんで病院作って もう面倒見ないぐらいお互いに愛情ない憎しみの世界作ったんですかね
なんで老人ホーム作るんですかね
親を無視してるからでしょ
仏教は老人ホーム作りません
親は神様だと大事に思うんだから
私は言ってますよ 仏教のことに
親がね もう老人ホームは格好いいやと行きたいと
怒られますよ 子供たちに
冗談じゃないんだと 自分で面倒見たいんです
ずっと亡くなるまで お母さんとかお父さんとかね
寝たきりになっても だからいらんですよ
彼らいうのはもう百人殺して一人に水をあげたと
一人に包帯巻いてあげたと
立派でしょう 私はと 勝手にすれば
一人も殺してないんだから
だから怪我怪我してる人いないでしょうに
仏教の周りは なんで包帯巻く必要あるんですかね
だからそういう臭いものへりくそですよ
そういうことです 一応
もしわからなかったらもっと続けてどうぞ
結構ですから 大丈夫ですよ
いや 何も先生 結局決定的かって追い込まってるわけじゃないんですから
他に誰かありましたらどうぞ
何 続きかな？続けていいのが
もし もし その前  ミャンマーのケースというのはね
フィリピンどうでしょうか？インドネシアどうでしょうか
イランやらイラクやらね
まあどこでもどうでしょうかね
例えばイラクはあの また独裁政権でしょうし
それで抑えていたんではないかと
で そこがなくなってしまったら
イラク人が本当に真面目な法律守る人間だったら自分の財産奪っちゃったんだからね
もう何でしたっけ あの博物館やらね
建物 イスラム教で何一つ盗んではいけないんですよ
そこで他宗教の人々にまで断食の時食うなよと
例えばサウジアラビアで仕事に行ったらば観光できません
だからあの国は仕事に行った人でも断食の時は何一つ食べてはいけない
食べたら殴られます 逮捕されます
そんなこと他人 他宗教の人にまでそんなこと言いながら
自分たちは何なのかと
だから自分やっぱりちょっと緩くなっちゃうと
もうまあ国そのものになるでしょうし
だから この たとえば それからカンボジアとかね
長い間もうたくさん人を殺されちゃったでしょうに
もともと仏教だから もうずーっと言っぱなしで
これは不公平 何とかしなさい
全然ヨーロッパは見ようともしなかったでしょうに
お坊さんたちはまとめて殺すとかね
あるでしょ テレビでよく見るでしょ
すごい殺すぞと こうやって山積みにしてたりとかね
あれほど殺されたら何の憎しみも色味も持ってないんですよ
すぐ平和になっちゃったんです
だからアカシヤさんもすごい人だとみんなに褒め
世界的に褒められるようになりましたけど
結局は自分が仕事にいった場が良かったんです
だったらイラクでもやってみてほしいんですけど
それは悪口で言うんではなくて
私もイラク人も平和でいてほしいんだからね
でもその時は歯が立たないんですよ
アフガンではそう簡単じゃないんですよ
だから仏教は本当に平和主義です
いくらひどい目に遭わされても
すぐそれを忘れて許してあげる
なぜかで仏教ではこの許すことってのはすごいかっこいいと思ってるんですよ
自分の子供を殺されても
殺した側のことも心配するということは
これはすごいかっこいいことやと
これこそ仏教徒やと思ってます
これ自慢に思ってるんです
だからキリスト教と考え方違うんです
不正が独裁政権やってると
キリスト教のアメリカには大変迷惑やというのはどういう理屈ですかね
それで世界を助けてる
助けてるんじゃなく殺してるだけでしょうに
学校なんか作ってるでしょ
裏あるでしょ いつでも
我々を愛して あまりたまらなく我々のことを愛してるんだから
立派な学校を作ってるんですかね
違うでしょうに すべて権力をとにかくそこで教育者を作って握ろうっていう話でしょう
だからごちそうを食べて
そいつに この人に糖尿病にさせて早く殺させますよということで
毎日信じられない物質ごちそうをあげるんだからって褒めるのはちょっと早すぎです
持ってくるのはごちそうかもしれませんだけど
狙いは早くも糖尿病にさせちゃって
こう血圧にさせられることなんです
これは私はなんでこういう態度で喋りますかというと
この話が早いんですよ
曖昧で喋るよりは  [咳]話が早いんです
ピシッと言った方が それ私の怠けかもしれませんけどね
[笑い]一応あの 仏教の国々にもね
いろんなところから戦争をかけたことはありましたけどね
それでもすごくいろいろするが
すごく自分の国を守るんです
どうしても守らなくなって潰れる時は
まあ世の中っていうのは無常だからそんなもんよ
例えば自分の国ではもうそろそろ仏教は消えると思いますよ
完全にキリスト教に押さえられて
かなり人々殺されると思います
テロたちが正しいと言ってるんだからね
殺された側が間違っていると
そんな話はないんですけど
仏教徒たちがね まあもう手も足も出ないし
歯も立たないし で 今の総理がこの最高裁判所まで弾劾させようと
いろいろ何か言ったんだと
判決は自分の好みに出してくれなかったということで
そんなことで今大統領を解任していますけどね
大統領は一人だけのはあの女の人はね
仏教徒を守ってやるぞと
これ無理 一人だけでは
世界的に悪人として描こうとしてるんだからね
仏教はどうせ悪人役やらなくちゃいけないんだからね
キリスト 立派なキリスト教の国で
まあこれはこれでまあいいんで
でも私もでも私も悲しいんだけど
まあ世の中っていうのはそういうものだからねっていうところで落ち着いてるんです
そんなのはまあ避けられないんだと
泣いてどうするんだ 例えば火山爆破して溶岩が流れてきて
家やらもう全部焼けちゃって
それなりに逃げ 逃げ切れなくなっちゃって
まあ死んだと これで泣いてわめてどうしますか
やっぱりそんなもんだなと
一切はまあ変化するんで無常であるんだと
ということで落ち着きますよ
でもこちらの方が頭がいいんだから
そう簡単じゃないんですよ
何も戦わないんだけど
なかなか抑えることは難しいんです
イギリス植民地の時代で
スリランカを頑張っても頑張っても取ることできなかったんです
あれほど軍隊を持って軍隊持たない国民を抑えることはできない
武器持たない国民を抑えることはできない
だって武器も何も持ってない人を殺さないでしょうに
向こうはもうさっさと
もう左 右 左 右で行くでしょうに
だから敵であるはずの村人たちは何のことなく畑を作ったり
羊を群れてみたり だったら軍人がお腹が喉が渇いて
あんた喉乾いた はい 水どうぞとあげたりとかすることだから
軍隊は中に入るんですけど
もう敵がいないんだから
これ戻らなくちゃいかない
また自分のキャンプに
それいたずらするんですよ
シンハラ民族は 道を閉鎖するんです
ただそれだけ だから閉鎖するために道は作らない
元々 みんなそうやって行けばいいんだからね
誰の庭でも変遷関係ないんだから
向こうに それで戻ろうと思ったら来た道がないんですよ
いろいろまあ石が 結構大きな石がもう落ちているとか
あーこっち石があっちではないかとか
で かなり迷子になったって
これでえらく怯えちゃって
あー大変なことになっちゃった
もうみんな殺されるぞと
言ったっても そうも殺されてない
一人も えらく苦労して食べ物もなくなって
なんとか戻る だからまた農民たちがニコッと笑って
これでいろいろ工夫してからくりをして
この王様を捕まってこいと言うと
悪い最悪の王でしたから
じゃあ持ってきなさいよと
どうせ外国にいるんだからいらんと
でもそこで誤解があったんで
仏教徒たちはね あんた方にはこの国はね
ブッダに守られてる国は支配できませんという気持ちがあったんです
だからお釈迦様の仏舎利法をね
隠して持っていったん隠しておいたんですけどね
ブッダの国やと で これで王は捕まったんだから
国は我々のものであると勝手に発表するんです
国民は は？何それっていう感じで
それで土地は奪われるわ
家からみんな追い出されるわ
すごい ずーっと長い間ものすごいことをやらせちゃったんですけどね
で 仕事はない 土地も奪われて
仕事を欲しければキリスト教になれとかね
で キリスト教そちらの学校出てないとダメで
いろいろ例えばインドからテノ人ボンボン連れてきて仕事をさせたり
やっぱりずっともうイギリス人が怯えていたんであって
戦わない人間に対しては
はい よく仲良くやったんですよ
で じゃあ国をそんなに統治したければね
あなた方は紳士たちでしょうと
ちゃんと法律的に国を守ることでしょう
だったら契約かをしましょうと
世界であり得ない話で
それでシンハラの偉い貴族の人々はちゃんとこれこれこのこの項目はあなた方は守るべきである
で 国の政治は偉大なる大英国帝国の王様に委ねますと
そんな契約を交わさったってもあまり有効でないということもまた知ってるしね
国っていうのはみんなのものだから
誰かさんの特別なものじゃないでしょうに
あの馬鹿なイギリス人たちがそれで契約交わしちゃって
あれは泣いたそうですよ
あの総督は ここまでできなかった
この小さな島をね 征服できなかったと
誰にも で 私は我々の偉大なる王様のためにできたことは大変ということで
もう涙ながらに書いた文章とかがありますけどね
で それでまあ一ヶ月か二ヶ月たって契約を破っちゃうでしょ
向こうは これでこちらは契約にはこうありますけど
あなた方は紳士でしょうと言って
最終的に戦う イギリスには行く
で あなたは 委任した総督がこういうことをやっているんだと
やめさせてくださいと
ちゃんとやめさせてくれる
仏教のお祭りは全て禁止という命令を出したんです
野蛮人のお祭りは禁止やと
そこでイギリスに行って
この五番目 この契約書でね
仏教と我々の伝統的な神々を信仰するお祭りやらね
それはすべて政治家として守るんだと約束だよと
今までも我々の王様そうやってきたんだと
この法律は何なのかと
取り消すと 一発で取り消すんですよ
それで認める 仏寺のペラハラ祭りとか
認めたら仏教徒たちが一人でやってるでしょ
ペラハラ祭りは それは面白くない
で また攻撃する いてまた契約書持って行って
これは今まで王様が主催でやったものであると
今あなた方でしょうにと
だからイギリスの王様の代表でちゃんとやりなさいよというと
はい わかりましたと で
総督の前で総督の  粗祭で
主催で仏寺のペラハラ祭り
時々あの人々は嫌味でね
ある文章を書くんです
イギリスに なんで我々は偉大なるキリスト教の信仰
神を信じる我々は この野蛮人の宗教に炎上挙げて面倒見なくちゃいけないんでしょうかとか
もうしょうがないんだから
もう そこで第二次世界戦争の場合はもう植民地でしょ
軍隊に入らなくちゃいけない
で もう強引に入れちゃうんですね
入れちゃうと人殺しに連れて行くでしょ
するんですよ 仏教の人々っていうのは
みんなもう言うんだったら入りますよ
給料ちゃんとくれくれと
しかし我々は だから人を殺せませんよと
絶対殺せませんよと どうしますかね
軍人は それで 言ったらイギリスはじゃあわかりましたと
もうどうにもならんだから
この人言うこと聞かんから
それでまあ他の仕事 いわゆるテント作ったり
料理を作ったり 物を物質を運んだりとか
そういう裏の裏方の仕事に回した
いいんじゃないか それで
お金ももらうわ 食べ物もあるわ
それだけじゃないんですよ
いろんな国々は戦争の時はすごい苦しんだでしょうね
食べ物も何もなく 我々はこの大変ということを知ったことじゃないんですよ
戦争終わってからの ああ
食べ物がない どうしようかとかね
知ったことはない ちゃんとイギリス人が面倒見てくれたんです
だから この今更考えると
ものすごい豪華な皿とか
我々はほとんど葉っぱで食べてる人間でしょうし
だから私たちのこの何て言いますか
この目が結構きついんですよ
物を買う時でも かなり品質のいい豪華なものにすぐ目が行くんです
だってもう昔イギリス人が作った最高のものばっかり入れてやったんだから
もう無茶苦茶ですよ とにかく
あの今もう原始的ですけど
あの国は でもどこかでバランス崩れてるんです
目は高いわ もう一番高いものしか手が行かないわとかね
それで経済的な状態といえば最悪で
まあ無茶苦茶ところ一個あるんですけど
私が言いたかったのは
やっぱりあれほどイギリス帝国にもそのちっぽけな
戦うと死ぬんだよとブッダが教えているんだから
勝ったっても また殺される
どうにもならん だったら戦わして勝つ
だからはっきり僕 知恵に勝るものはありませんと
体力 暴力っていうのは知恵の前ではね
何の意味もないんだと
ホタルの光と太陽の光のようなものやと
体力 暴力の力は 知恵は太陽の光のようなものであると
だからいっぱいいい加減なところあるんだけど
ブッダからちょっとちょっと奪ってパクったところで
ものすごく命を守られてるんです
だから我々から見れば
神様にあれほど祈りしているのに
あんた方は殺されてるでしょうと
我々はなんでこんなに平和でいるんでしょうかと
違うでしょ だから私たちは互いに助けることって当たり前のことだと思っているし
だから乞食が何か食べ物やらお金くれという場合でも
態度でかいんですよ 仏教の場合は
惨めじゃないんです 私はそういうことで苦しんでるんだから
何とかちょうだいというか
態度で言うんです それで
あんたなんでこの乞食のくせにそんな
そう思わないんですよ
言われた側は やっぱり自分がいい立場にいるんだから
人を助けるのはこれは当たり前のことです
それでできるだけのはいはい
これっていうことであげたりするし
また仲良く仲良く同士でいる世間話もするんです
そうですね この頃はやっぱりね
政治が悪いですねとかね
だからこの雰囲気はもうなかなかね
他の現代文化の人々にはちょっとわからないんですね
なんで我々は何の躊躇もなく人の家に入りますか？とかね
行儀が悪いってはないんですよ
かえって何が悪いんですか？って態度なんです
だから子供をしつける叱るということは
大人が誰にでも平気でやっちゃうと
あんた誰ですか？と子供は聞かないんです
だからそこら辺でね ダメな子供でもいいんじゃないか
子供だから もう大人の仕事ではないかという態度なんです
だから子供はどこへ行ったかわからないと全然親が心配しない
それはどこか行ってるでしょうと
そのうち来るでしょうという態度
今はそこでもないんですけど
前はそういうことでしたからね
ご飯食べる時間にいなかったら
まあ親は一応一応置くんですけど
もう食べてくるんで どこかで
それで知らない家でご飯食べたんだからと親が言って
またそれに謝ったりとかはしないんです
別に この間 うちの子は本当にお世話になりまして
申し訳ありませんとかね
まあそれって何と言いますか
と何かお土産持って行ったりとかね
それもない まあそれは日本の文化でそれなりにいいことなんですけど
そこまでもない だからなんとなく野蛮的に見えるんですよ
でも思考が別なんですよ
あげた側が これ子供でしょうに
ご飯食べるとこはご飯
子供にご飯あげるのは大人の仕事でしょうに
じゃあ君置いてご飯食べなさい
ちゃんと食べなさい その時にしつけはする
残らず食べなさいとかね
子供にとって別に親も親もうるさいし
このおばさんもうるさいぐらいの
感じで もう食べて また遊んでもう行ったり帰ったりするぐらいのものでね
今みたいなアトピーやらそういうこともなかったしね
だから結構すごく気楽な穏やかな
ものすごい自然に近い生き方なんですよ
仏教は 推薦しているのは
水と空気と植物と一緒に生きるという